a Dutch company has invented the world's
first electronic joint that's right
Dutch manufacturer is e and joint
claimed that the e spliff is totally
harmless contains no tobacco nicotine or
even THC so just to be clear what's
going on here is the THC that's the part
that sort of the mental hi that's gonna
make you laugh and all that but the
stuff that has the medicinal benefits is
not so you can get the medicinal
benefits without having the other part
of it we've got an image of the e joint
the en joint it looks like an
e-cigarette basically but nice marijuana
leaf so you know what you're doing
they're not to confuse you it's got the
the shape of real joint obviously a
chrome-plated tip where the cannabis
leaf lights up with every puff it's
available in six fruit flavors and they
are currently 10,000 of these things
sold everyday in Europe and you know
they want to get it of course to
Amsterdam where weed is already legal
although they've been taken back some of
their rights on that pretty good right
this this seems all good we got no
problem with we eat at this table
I hope I'm surprised first of all what
way - you know innovate the Dutch you
know they're the ones that tax and prop
that started tax prostitutes you know
they're they're like let's hey there's a
supply or if there's a if there's a
demand
let's supply it and that's what they're
doing here I'm surprised that there's
only six flavors yeah the prostitutes
literally have a union they're in a
union and they have to go for STD
testing yeah every so often the
government makes money off it so this
could be another example of that so if
you took the mental hiya and this was
just medicinal is there any real 'evil
anyways but i mean like we can see the
benefit to this if there's like a child
or something you know that would need
the medical benefits right of something
without getting high you know obviously
you know you don't wanna be like oh here
a little Johnny take this we've you
smoked it but if it helps them you know
really pain then I totally agree with
that but one of my first for this
article to be honest like I I kind of
laughed a little bit I'm like okay so
it's got no nicotine it's got no tobacco
it's got no THC but it's got like this
marijuana leaf on it and people are like
getting all excited about it like oh
look at this awesome new
I'm like well first of all I've seen
electronic joints for a long time so
this isn't like something that was new
or shocking to me right but the fact
that they're able to take out all those
things and use it for purely medicinal
purposes is exciting that's a good thing
do we need this in America or do we just
need to get or do we just need to get it
legalized period the way it's going from
state to state right now and exactly
should as legalized periods they're
taxing prostitution and stuff why don't
we tax marijuana I mean that would help
so many things Detroit take some notes
off of Amsterdam they're real innovative
you know fine fine new business ventures
to invest in they're cutting off water
in Detroit as we did in the other
segment where maybe a little weed
profiteering yeah yeah yeah I'd be good
for taxing the hookers there's a lot in
Detroit yeah what do you make of the
people that I see at some level even
though I don't agree with them I can
somehow get the people that don't want
people to be stoned because they're
gonna be stupid and driving I don't
agree with it and it's there's nothing
true about it but but what about the
people that are still saying no for
medicinal purposes a gateway everything
is a gateway to regular food and then
they were just in something else you
know to me like I I just don't see it is
it's crazy especially since there's
nothing in this that would be addictive
that would be a gateway to anything what
it's not even gonna get you high yeah
you know it's like pretty much taking
medicine so is it because Big Pharma is
not behind this yet is that the idea
because we love everything in pill form
so if there were medicinal benefits to
this in in this form until a big farm is
behind it you know we never get the
marketing to get everyone ginned up for
it you think that oh my god it's got a
marijuana leaf on it yeah it's like they
can profit off of it I think I think
once you get a big company behind it
manufacturing it just like big tobacco
in the 80s and the 90s and Pfizer and
the other big drug companies once you
get a big corporation behind it who's
you know donating money to major
political campaigns
everyone's gonna be back on board
especially is as you guys are saying
there's no actual negative side effects
that impair judgment
from weight from what they're telling us
and if they're telling us yeah we got to
believe it right would that appeal to
you to smoke something that we you would
get sort of none of the the mental stuff
we but just get the physical stuff you
know your shoulder hurts you smoke back
you feel a little better instead of
taking Advil or something probably you
know want the THC in there but could you
maybe sprinkle it on top yeah yeah
that'll be something inject the
marihuana's all right yeah legalize it
for God's sakes every week with the weed
come on kids